inflation official number 6.8 percent
first question is is that accurate based
on what you're seeing both e-commerce
and also uh within the business and then
two is do you think it's accelerating
decelerating like what are you seeing
just kind of on the ground when it comes
to you know wages uh kind of cost of
goods etc yeah i'm really worried about
it because we're
i don't know how we so we have to raise
interest rates and they've already
announced i think three three coming up
um
uh but you know our debt is 130 so our
debt coverage is going to go up as we
raise interest rates so i worried we're
we've kind of worked ourselves into a
real real tough spot um i i can't solve
that i just worry about it and keep an
eye on it um you know what we're hearing
from our our you know we have like four
over 400 hourly employees and what we're
hearing is we've given them pay
increases because we're a premium brand
we can kind of you know do better than
our competitors that in the labor market
um but you know we've moved people from
like let's say 12 to 18 and they're kind
of saying you know that's not enough my
my food bills have doubled in you know
the stuff for my kid and my health care
and um so we're definitely feeling that
we consume a lot of oil as we do oil
changes that price has been wonky and we
drive a lot of vans around and you know
fuel prices have gone gone up um
so i think we'll be fine uh
but yeah i think it's definitely higher
than than than what the government
that's why i showed you that meme um you
know i think cpi is probably needs a
dusting off and another you know
smart people looking at that one because
i don't think it's capturing you know
like i read one uh one article where the
way they capture rent payments is they
do a survey of like 50 people or some
insanely small number of people but then
there's data in the world today when
they admitted cpi this data didn't exist
but there's probably six data sources we
can go to now and see what rents are
doing so those 50 people say it's up
eight percent but when you look at the
data it's up like 12 or 14
so so i i when you know i think that
it's not capturing a big chunk of what's
going on
yeah and uh you mentioned going from
twelve dollars an hour to eighteen
dollars an hour is that on average you
would say that you uh didn't blend
across our our markets and all our
technicians yeah i mean that's a 50 inch
you know i'm not a mathematician here
but like that's really really high uh
when you see something like that are you
all increasing prices as well uh to kind
of combat some of the increased gasoline
uh kind of labor et cetera like how do
you think about okay we have you know a
nice margin because we're a premium
brand so we can eat into a little bit of
it but at what point do you say like no
we have to pass some of this to the
consumer and raise prices as well
yeah we've already done taken several
price increases
yeah yeah and yeah the yeah and then you
know the way we fight it um you know so
there's there's a couple ways is uh you
know uh i can't go to my shareholders
and say hey i know you i know i told you
our margins were this and now we're
gonna
lower them you know that
so so i got to keep my margins right so
the way we protect it is we
we increase prices but then we're always
relentlessly automating things we're
touching 3000 vehicles a day right now
and when you do that you start to find
these little little kind of things that
will save five minutes but you multiply
that times three thousand vehicles and
money comes out of that right so that's
where um yeah i forget which of your
brothers said it we are we do have like
a physical world but a lot of our
innovation is on the software side too
and hardware side so we've invented we
talked about the map we've got like 10
other inventions we've come up with um
that you know like another example is
our you know we were looking at some
data and our technicians spent a lot of
time vacuuming pepper so now we have a
vacuum that has a little agitator in it
and some other technology that
addresses pepper
millions of little things like that you
got to kind of kind of relentlessly
focus on those so that you get more
automation and then that plus raising
prices should enable us to keep our
margins where they are and what i love
about it is
you know we there's a there's old saying
in software that there's these things
that can only be done linearly and and
uh you know fred brooks uh he wrote this
book the mythical man month he uses this
example nine women can't make a baby in
a month like you know making you know
gestating babies isn't something you can
you can share
and a lot of these things we've learned
we couldn't have done unless we were
doing 3 000 cars a day and when we get
to 4 000 we'll learn another set of
things it that's our competitive mode
is those those automations that we've
baked in there that gives us pricing
power and the ability to hit our margins
at scale that we're at and um there's an
analyst brad slingerland you may know
him he ran the janus 20 technology fund
for a while he came out with a note he
called it um digital companies that have
an analog component and he used amazon
tesla and carvana i kind of that's a
good set of companies to be with so so i
kind of put us in that bucket but
there's this really interesting things
when you match that digital innovation
with the analog world that we're seeing
and uh that are innovating and that's a
lot of fun and i'm really enjoying that
as well